hi my name is mark mothersburg and i
make rugs
let's check out the rugs over here
luxurious
uh you know i'm a
visual artist
i
went to school
in ohio at kent state i was a
making major
and then
i thought i was gonna
be an art teacher
but by accident
i had a band and they accidentally had
some hit records and then we ended up
going all over the world and moved to
california and i but i still always
made art and showdown
and
about eight years ago i started showing
in galleries again
and
a few years ago about five years ago i
kind of got spores with
paper and
11 or 12 years ago that just had a logo
on it and walked across it every day and
always liked it
so
i didn't see anything i liked when i
went shopping for rugs so
i checked into putting my own artwork on
rugs and
they found a company in china that would
do it for me
and then i started doing them one at a
time and then
it became addictive i really liked the
way they looked and
if i had to take a picture of my
daughter i liked taking a picture on a
different rug every time and
and
it was kind of fun because the rugs you
get you know the longer they're in your
house you know it's like things happen
like when the baby pukes on it and
they've got a little spot here but they
kind of you always remember oh she was
on she was just had two teeth back then
that was so sweet you know you have
those kind of memories that stick with
it too and um
so you know flash forward
five six years well i started in 2002 so
five minutes forward
um now i i ended up with a garage full
of rugs and i thought well
maybe i should do something with it so
i'm gonna
i'm gonna um
see if anybody else likes them and maybe
maybe they'd fit in somebody else's
house if i don't have a house big enough
oh i can see that they're all over the
floor all over the walls
some of them
are made out of wool and silk some of
the bigger ones that are you can't see
them now they're mostly rolled up right
now
and and they're the kind of finer ones
here are made out of nylon and they're
much more durable and
you can throw a party and let people
throw up on
my therapy
i draw on postcard size paper and i i
used to write lyrics and
so i'd save those pieces of paper and i
think oh you know what i might need some
lyrics when we do this record so i start
saving all these cards
and then they became my image bank and
so all of these to sell them all were
once i painted them on a piece of paper
about four by six inches and then i took
the ones i liked the most
and then blew them up
and then worked in photoshop i would add
colors sometimes
like this one here it's kind of
changed in the sense that on the
original piece of paper that i wrote him
on
i had found a pack of google eyes at a
store and i said so those things there
actually were really three-dimensional
globalized but i had to give them up
so that's that's how that works
but
it's turned out to be it's like a medium
i like to work in it's just it feels
good
i like it better than paper and um
it looks
they're kind of unexpected when you see
them on the floor
you know
like if you have something like a little
ghost floating out from underneath your
sofa it's kind of a nice look